[Música]
será que vocês entendem o real
significado da palavra estupro
meu caso eu entendi o real significado
dessa palavra ainda muito pequena ainda
criança ea partir desse descobrimento
eu comecei a transformar a minha dor não
sonho luta como também uma ferramenta
para ajudar outras mulheres que às vezes
nem sabem que sofreram esse tipo de
abuso
eu sou moradora do subúrbio do rio de
janeiro e eu me identifico como
feminista dois fatos que não costumam
caminhar muito juntos se você entende
que eu passei a maior parte da minha
vida como moradora do subúrbio e
afastada dos privilégios da elite
carioca costuma desfrutar um deles o
debate da desigualdade de gênero mas a
minha indicação como feminista
ela saiu muito a partir da inspiração da
história da minha mãe a minha mãe ela
saiu de uma cidadezinha do sertão de
pernambuco na cidade chamada lajedo
ela filha com um filho de um casal que
tinha mais 12 filhos e veio para o rio
na verdade foi para o rio de janeiro
então tá uma melhor qualidade de vida
mas nem tudo foram flores para ela na
verdade foram muito mais espinhos do que
flores a chegar na cidade maravilhosa
ela se deparou com muitas dificuldades e
quando ela tinha 21 anos
eu nasci e foi nesse momento que a minha
mãe se viu sozinha com a filha recém
nascida no colo e sem ter onde dormir
nós passamos muitas das nossas noites
num banco de praça
durante o dia a minha mãe ela trabalhava
como empregada doméstica na casa de
algumas madames e à noite na gestão da
água mas por um banco da praça onde nós
passávamos a noite eu no seu seio e ela
acordada tentando me proteger de que
alguma coisa ruim acontecesse
foi assim com essa trajetória da minha
mãe que eu aprendi que eu deveria ser
forte e não me deixe não me deixar
abater por nenhum programa que eu
sofresse que eu sabia que no final eu ia
aprender com aqueles problemas eles
iriam me amadureceu de alguma forma e de
fato a minha mãe ela conseguiu construir
não só um contato pra nós dois como
também da condição de trazer algum dos
seus irmãos para o rio para tentar dar
uma melhor qualidade de vida pra eles e
com a chegada deles que foram cinco
irmãos
duas irmãs ea minha avó
a história triste poderia começar a ter
um final feliz agora mas na verdade era
só o começo da história
a gente morava numa casa típica de
subúrbio do rio uma casa com quintal
grande com muitas árvores e muitas
maneiras malditas bananeiras porque foi
em baixo daquelas bananeiras que eu
descobri o real significado da palavra
estupro foi em baixo daquelas bananeiras
que três dos meus tios me tocaram que
três dos meus tios abusaram sexualmente
de mim
lembranças que hoje eu carrego com muita
clareza e que me dói mas que durante a
maior parte da minha infância e
adolescência e reprime e recalque e
esqueci delas um pouco como mecanismo de
defesa
esses meus tios eles trouxeram muitos
problemas para minha mãe independente
disso e mesmo sem saber do que tinha
acontecido em baixo daquelas bananeiras
ela mandou que eles voltassem para a sua
cidade natal usando esse pássaro 14 anos
para ser mais específica e um desses
meios fios retornou para o rio de
janeiro ea minha mãe que sempre quis
ajudar muito a família recebeu ele na
nossa casa e colocou para dormir no
quarto junto comigo na cama ao lado da
minha
no meu íntimo eu sabia que tinha alguma
coisa errada eu sabia que não não tava
certa a minha relação com ele
eu sabia que alguma coisa tinha com
tudo mas eu tinha uma sensação na minha
cabeça que era um pesadelo
não conseguia acreditar que alguma coisa
podia ter acontecido mesmo de fato e foi
antes de dormir ele me faz uma pergunta
ele pergunta faz uso de medicamentos
contraceptivos e é quando respondo que
não porque de fato na época não fazia
uso de nenhum medicamento
e é quando ele diz uma uma frase uma
frase que marca uma ruptura na minha
memória
ele diz mas quando você era pequena você
era muito safadinha e naquele momento
que um gatilho vem na minha mente
naquele momento que lembra com clareza
de tudo o que aconteceu embaixo daquelas
bananeiras
agora tudo fazer sentido na minha cabeça
e eu me desespero porque eu estou do
lado do meu agressor
agora tinha certeza que eu estava
dormindo na cama ao lado do meu
estuprador e eu fecho os olhos e peço
ajuda para sua proteção de todos os
poderes sobrenaturais para que nada de
ruim aconteça e é assim que consigo
pegar no sono
o dia amanhece em meu quarto e clareia e
quando o acordo
quando eu acordo e vir para o lado eu
vejo ele observando com olhares famintos
olhares de quem deseja abocanhar uma
presa e eu me assusto imediatamente o
vira para a parede novamente e ficou
pedindo para que nada aconteça para que
nada aconteça que aquilo não é real não
é real ele não pode ser capaz de fazer
isso mas ele é ele sobe pra minha cama
ele me agarra com força me segura na
cama enquanto acaricia o meu corpo e eu
tenho que ter forças
eu tento criar força dentro de mim para
reagir aquilo e quando consigo levantar
e correr em pranto e falar com a minha
mãe sobre tudo que está acontecendo
a minha mãe se sente também super tocada
super ferida porque o irmão que ela
tentou
a que ela foi para o rio de janeiro
então tá ajudar a família
agora estava tentado violentá a sua
própria filha
é um momento muito difícil não só pra
mim quanto também para a minha mãe
a partir disso algumas algumas atitudes
minhas mudaram eu comecei agir de alguma
forma diferente é minha mãe sabia que
era decorrência da quele trauma
então é muito sábia e decidimos colocar
numa psicóloga decidiu buscar ajuda de
uma psicóloga para melhorar
e de fato foi uma das melhores decisões
que minha mãe já tomou na minha vida
a partir dessa experiência de
compartilhar aquilo que eu carregava
aquela dor de compartilhar aquela
memória dos meus três anos que só eu
sabia aquilo começou a me libertar
daquele mau eu comecei cada vez que eu
falava com a psicóloga cada vez que eu
falava com a minha família cada vez que
eu falava com amigos mais próximos
aquilo ia me libertando eu senti aquele
peso não era só meu mas foi assim que eu
comecei a perceber o quanto falar
publicamente sobre isso o quanto tornar
o debate sobre a cultura do estupro
pública é importante que cada vez que
nós falamos mais disso a gente pode se
atentar para que isso acontece
diariamente com pessoas próximas agentes
e foi nesse momento que eu comecei a me
entender enquanto ativista pelos
direitos das mulheres porque ainda hoje
no brasil a cada 11 minutos uma mulher
ainda é estuprada
esses números eles vão se tornando ainda
mais assustadores quando a gente entende
que só 10% dessas mulheres têm coragem
de denunciar e 70% desses números são
crianças e adolescente assim como eu é
também base esses números que eu posso
falar que no em 2016
em maio de 2016 para ser mais específica
um caso tomou grande repercussão na
mídia que foi o caso de um estupro
coletivo que a condição na zona oeste do
rio de janeiro
uma menina de 16 anos 16
anos foi estuprada por 33 homens 30 em
três homens e foi os foi a onu me
encontrar com esse caso que eu e
mulheres do nossas uma organização que
fazia parte até então
nos sentimos muito impotente em relação
a isso nós já estávamos muito
mobilizados pela causa
a gente tinha acabado de realizar o
circuito mulheres mobilizados que foi
uma semana inteira durante o 8 de março
realizando ações propositivas para
debater o direito da mulher à cidade
a gente tinha acabado de barrar um
projeto de lei na assembléia legislativa
que pretende criminalizar ainda mais o
aborto a gente já estava debatendo sobre
isso mas quando se falou do estupro a
gente não sabe o que fazer
é isso que muitos de nós sentimos como
que a gente consegue impedir que mais
estupros aconteciam que a gente entende
que é um ato que acontece apenas entre o
estuprador e a vítima então como é que
eu vou conseguir chegar lá impedir que
isso aconteça de fato pode ser que não
consiga macia vítima que a gente pode
fazer pela mulher que já foi violentada
e é assim que nosso mapa do acolhimento
é também base que a minha experiência
enquanto mulher vítima de violência
sexual que ter buscado a ajuda de uma
psicóloga e todo esse tratamento me
ajudou a superar esse mal me ajudou a me
libertar desses fantasmas e poder estar
lutando por outras mulheres foi
entendendo todo esse processo meu que a
gente enxergou que outras mulheres
precisavam passar por isso também
precisavam de ajuda de psicólogos e
terapeutas respostas atendê-los mapa de
acolhimento é um projeto que tem como
base a ajudar outras mulheres a gente
costuma usar uma frase que é nenhuma
mulher merece sofrer sozinho e é de fato
isso nenhuma mulher merece sofrer
sozinho
hoje o mapa do acolhimento ele tem mais
ou menos umas três mil mulheres vão
áreas que são mulheres que se
disponibilizam para avaliar os serviços
públicos da sua cidade porque o estado
também tem um papel fundamental em se
responsabilizar por esses casos o estado
ele precisa exercer o seu papel enquanto
apa apa jantar a essas mulheres
mas enquanto o estado não muda enquanto
esses serviços não funcionam porque em
muitas cidades não funciona
o mapa do acolhimento tá aí pra isso pra
colher essas mulheres hoje mapa está em
três estados em 13 em algumas cidades
inclusive que em blumenau são mais ou
menos 476 se eu não me engano terapeutas
que já se voluntariaram para atender
mulheres vítimas ea gente tem uma faixa
de quase 100 mulheres que são vítimas
que já se inscreveram e já estão
recebendo atendimento inclusive sou uma
delas que faz uso no mapa do alimento
só para relembrar um pouco ainda hoje
agora enquanto estava falando aqui
uma mulher foi estuprada
esses números ele continua o relógio não
pára mais mulheres estão sendo
estupradas
será que agora será que depois de nesse
meu relato
vocês conseguem entender um pouco melhor
o que significa a palavra estupro
se sim eu quero que saiamos daqui
comprometido a tentar mudar um pouco da
realidade pelo menos próxima da gente
então tá mudar um pouco da manhã
tanto a fazer hoje para mudarmos o
amanhã dessa realidade
obrigada
[Aplausos]